hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
in vitrogen eyebrite analysis software
an introduction
and overview of key analysis workflows i
am jennifer woods of labrutz and i'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo fisher scientific
to learn more visit thermofisher.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation you may also submit any
technical issues here as well if you
have trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation i'd like to now
welcome our speaker
dr janaki narahari staff scientist
thermo fisher scientific dr narahari you
may now begin your presentation
thank you jennifer
thank you to all our audience today for
your interest in the ibrite
analysis software we'll begin with a
brief overview of
the hybrid imaging systems and then i'll
have a demonstration of the accompanying
analysis software
we conclude the session with some q a
okay we offer a series of instruments
starting from the entry level eyebright
cl750 imager
that is capable of imaging hemi plots
and gels to the high-end instrument that
is capable of
imaging up to four fluorescent channels
to suit all lab needs
all of them official scientific
eyebright instrument your instruments
can image
up to four uh blots or gels at a time
and they all contain a 9.1 megapixel
cool ccd camera
which is capable of capturing high
resolution images
our images allow onboard image analysis
to initially analyze up to four blocks
in an image as i've mentioned in my
previous slide
all images images are capable of imaging
multiple samples at a time so we unify
found it fit
to allow even image analysis to have
that kind of flexibility
so we do provide analysis software on
board as well as standalone
which is able to individually analyze
all the four samples
that has been imaged together here but
they can be analyzed separately
individually
so on the instrument we have basic
analysis
uh capabilities which allows you to do
densitometric analysis
molecular weight estimation as well as
normalization
for extensive analysis we offer
standalone eyebride image analysis
software
the images and the analysis performed on
the instrument can be directly exported
to the cloud for continuation of
analysis
or they can be exported to the network
drive
and then imported into the desktop
analysis
desktop analysis software you can also
export
your analysis in the images to the usb
stick and import it into the
desktop via a different route i will be
demonstrating all these three shortly
all the three uh methods of export and
re-import
they allow for a seamless transition of
analysis between an instrument and
analysis software
the eyebrite image analysis software is
available in multiple formats
to provide maximum flexibility the
desktop version is available for free
download on mac
as well as pc
the hybrid analysis software provides a
complete solution
providing tools for image adjustment
analysis
annotation report creation and other
features
these features cannot be comprehensively
covered in one hour
therefore i will go over the basic
utility and the location of features and
tools in today's seminar
we will have other presentations to go
over at a different time
to go through in-depth analysis
workflows that are available in the
hybrid analysis software
so now we will move to the our software
demonstration
so once you launch the eyebrite analysis
software
you land in the gallery page
so as i mentioned the gallery is the
landing page for the hybrid analysis
software
and it contains the management tools the
file management tools
as i previously mentioned if you have
exported the files directly from the
imager to the cloud
this is the page where all the image
files will land
if you had exported them to the network
drive
which was previously set up for the
ibret analysis
app then they can be easily synced using
the sync icon
however if you had exported them to the
thumb drive
or to a location elsewhere they can be
imported into the analysis
app using the import images tool under
the actions menu
the images are by default sorted
actually by date and the later the
most recent images are located right at
the top of the image gallery
doing so allows the user to easily
access their
most recent files however there are
other options to sort the gallery
so if a user is interested in looking at
images that were captured in a certain
mode
they can sort the gallery using the mode
so here as you can see the images that
were captured under a particular mode
are grouped together
or as we had previously seen when i
launched my app
if if you want to you see only your
recently used images
you can sort the gallery using the
recently used view
in this case all the files that you had
worked on in the previous one week
are grouped together so for further
processing
the image files need to be first added
to the tray
so the way that you can select and add
the images to the tray is by single
click
on the file so a single click adds the
file to the tray
and another click on the same
file actually will remove it from the
tray
so single click adds to the tray another
click it will remove the image from the
track
the other if you want to look at the
file name before you can select a file
hovering over the file over the
thumbnail
will now show you the name of the file
at the top and
also add the file to the preview window
in the preview window you can access all
the image information associated with
the file
so i'm going to select a few files to
take them
through our workflow
okay once you have selected all the
images and added to the tray
you can move to the next tab using as
i've mentioned either the next
button at the bottom or the tabs at the
top
so for today's presentation i'll move to
the next step using the tabs above
so this page is where all the
tools required for image adjustment are
located
so the tools in the zoom control and the
image options
they are applied to all the channels if
you have a multi-channel image
in the viewport i'm going to change the
image and select a chemi image because i
would like to demonstrate the
crop feature so as i've mentioned
the crop feature here is going to be
applied on both the channels the kemi
and the membrane so at this point i want
to
just give a little bit background about
our image display
itself before moving to the crop
so by default in the eyebrite image
analysis software
the display is always composite image
which means that it is an overlay
created with
all the channels in an image so for kemi
channel
when you are imaging on the eyebright
imager it captures a membrane image
as well as a kidney image so what you're
seeing here
is an overlay of the chemi channel and
the membrane channel together
the way to tell them separately is
or the way that you can identify how
many channels are being displayed in the
viewport is to look
at this area the view and edit channels
here you can see all the channels that
have been listed
and the eyeballs over here will tell you
which channels
are being displayed and if you do not
see a black eyeball
i was being shown that means that that
particular channel
is not in display so currently what i'm
showing you is that i have turned the
kemi channel off
so the same way you can just turn the
display of the channel back
on by clicking on the eyeball
so right now as i mentioned in the image
display it's a composite image
it contains two channels the kemi and
the membrane channel
so i'm going to walk you through the
image options
so this is the tool that a crop is the
tool that you can use to remove the
unwanted area
from your image for example in this
particular image that i'm showing we
have two blocks that have been imaged
however neither one of them are really
straight
so to get good analysis on the image you
do have to straighten
this particular plot however we cannot
achieve a perfect straight line
since both the blocks are not aligned so
what i'm going to do is to
crop each of those blocks individually
and then process them as two independent
samples
so to crop an image you select the crop
icon
it will show you an area you can
move the area around you can enlarge and
shrink
the age the cover the the area that is
covered by this particular
template that is being shown here is the
area that is going to be saved after
your crop
cropping all the areas surrounding this
particular
template here will be removed from your
file so once you're
happy with the area that you want to
crop
click save doing so will create a new
file and this is done to prevent
modification
of the original file the new file that
is created
retains the original file name
but it appends it with the word cropped
this way you can always trace it back to
the original file from which
this particular new file was created
now as you can see you can see the slant
in in the block
and you can straighten that using the
straighten
straighten too
you can turn the image by one degree
increments either to the
uh to the left or to the right in this
case it's pretty obvious that we'll have
to turn it towards the left
so i think this gives pretty straight
line so once you're done
straightening the image click on the
straighten tool again to make it to save
your
rotation and if you're not happy with
the rotation that you see since it you
know
the black background doesn't look
uniform you can perform
another crop event on that
so in this case i want to remove all the
black areas surrounding so that i don't
see
the angle of rotation there so see
so this is the feature that helps you to
clean clear up your image from an image
that wasn't properly image to start with
however i do want to uh emphasize the
fact that it is
much better to image the blocks
correctly
to begin with i write instrument does
have the auto rotation feature which if
you
use one sample at a time will straighten
the sample for you and therefore you may
not
have to straighten the image in the
analysis software
the other tools in this image options
are rotate
this will rotate the sample by 90
degrees
by a step of 90 degrees and flip you can
either flip horizontal or vertical
and inward when you apply
inward it just inverts all the channels
at the same time so as you had seen
before the
image that you're seeing showed the
black signal on the white background
and inverting it has inverted the signal
and now you see the white signal on the
black background
how it's always better to see the signal
as black on white since it's easier to
differentiate it over the background so
i'm going to invert it back
so these are the tools that we have
applied on all the channels
right i mean crop as you saw crop
rotation all of them
have uh have been applied on the image
as such so all the channels were taken
as one
and then it was uh all the options were
applied on all the modifications were
applied on all the channels
together however there are some other
tools that you can apply at on a single
channel
such as false color why do we need to
use the false color
again this is the best example that i'm
showing over here right you're looking
at both the kemi
and the signal from the membrane it's
really difficult for you to
differentiate what signal is coming from
which channel so one way to do that as
i've shown you
is to deselect the channel that you're
not interested in
however to you know estimate molecular
weight it's much better to
have to see the markers right on that so
i like to always keep the marker channel
on when i'm in the chemi mode so the
other way to differentiate it would be
to
apply false color to the signal from one
or the other channel
since to begin with the markers are wear
pre-stained markers i'd rather apply the
false color to the membrane channel
so i'll i'll show you how to do that we
can go down
to the false color accordion and
as you can see right now there's no
false color applied to either of the
channels
and to work with only a single channel
you have to select the channel for
editing
right and that is shown with this pencil
mark right now it's the kemi channel
that is selected so if i apply false
color it will be added to the kemi
channel
so i'm going to select the marker
channel membrane channel
and then i'll go to membrane here and
then
add the false color so now you can see
that the markers have been
uh labeled as blue so they're false the
blue false color has been applied
on the signal in the membrane channel
now it's very easy to distinguish
between
the signal coming from the membrane
versus that coming from
the chemi channel so what we have gone
over here is
how to select uh the channels for image
display versus editing we have seen how
to crop
or and rotate the images the zoom
controls i don't think uh
they're any difficult you can just zoom
in or zoom out
based on uh how you want to look at your
image
and how to apply false color now the
other part of image adjustment
is also to adjust the image display as
such right to make the
signal look darker or lighter and that
can be done
through the image display enhancement
section over here
so i'm going to go back and select the
chemical because that is what
we are mostly interested in i'm going to
turn off the membrane channel
just so that you can see the differences
in the image
in the contrast adjustments so to make
to make the signal look darker
right you can play around with the black
and white
to the level that you want to see you
know something that was
barely visible before you can now start
seeing it come
over the background right and if you're
not
happy with that you can always click
auto contrast again and it is going to
reset the image to the previous
auto contrast levels that were shown by
default
and if you don't want the uh that either
you want to look at your raw image you
can
click on the auto contrast again and now
you can see the full stretch
so this would be the raw image however
the
for good good image display you can
either go for auto contrast or do manual
adjustments to the
level that you wish
and this again the histogram changes are
applied
to a single channel at a time so if you
want you
uh to modify the look of your membrane
channel as well
you'll have to select that for editing
once you select the channel for editing
it is automatically
toggled on for display as well because
you can't edit the channel
without visually looking at it
so here you can adjust the membrane
channel as well
i'm going to make it a little bit
lighter
there we go
so those are the basic image adjustment
tools that are available over here
so the other tool that one needs to pay
attention to
is show saturation so when you
before you move to the analysis tab or
when you are performing analysis it is
essential for you to
look at the pixel saturation
as you know that once the pixel is
saturated it can no longer retain
or accumulate any more signal and
therefore
the analysis performed on saturated
pixel or near saturated pixel
is not accurate so to make sure that
your
data is worthy of analysis you can turn
on the show saturation
and as you can see that in the chemi uh
layer
there is no saturation seen in this or
in any of those bands so this image is
pretty good for us to perform analysis
on
and that is what we'll go next
okay so this is the analysis tab so as
soon as you move from
edges or from gallery directly into the
analysis the analysis software
automatically performs
an analysis for you and it displays the
identified lanes and bands
if you're unhappy with the analysis that
is performed
you can go and delete the frame so to
delete the frame
i'm going to turn off the saturation
over here
because the membrane channel is showing
too much of saturation so you cannot see
the frame
being selected so there you go and now
you can select the frame it is already
selected the first frame is always
selected by default
um and you can tell that by the magenta
color
so if you're not happy with the analysis
that is being
shown just go to the frames and select
the delete icon which is yeah you know
or right over here or
you can cancel that and then you can
also use the keyboard
delete function right on in the pc it is
directly
delete whereas if you have a mac you
have to do function and delete
to perform the same action and then you
can apply
at this point you have two options
either you can draw your own frame
to perform a re-analysis or go under
actions
and auto-analyze it again but we came
for analysis to begin with and we were
not
happy so i will not go and perform the
auto analysis again
there's also a third option you can go
to the manual
and you can select the region types
and then identify the areas that you
want to analyze you know you can draw
the boxes
you can copy the box and paste it
so this is the region analysis right and
you can
resize and then you can move
but before you move you have to deselect
the region
and then you can move it but for today's
demonstration we are not going to be
spending much time
uh on manual analysis so i'm going to
cancel it
and exit it out and come back to the
automatic analysis
and i'm going to define my own frame
i'm going to get it as close as possible
so yeah you do
have to use the minimum frame size you
know just clicking it once will not
add a frame and here i'm going to delete
that because that's not the correct
frame that i wanted to draw
so just hold the mouse down and drag it
on the area that you want to add the
frame and then apply if you're satisfied
and then you can see the analysis has
been performed
as you can see the lighter bands are
still not detected
so i can go to the lanes and bands and
add the bands
by selecting add band option
or the other way to add a band would be
to copy a band
but before you copy a band deselect that
icon
and paste it and you can move it to the
new location
right but to add a single band
uh one at a time when so many if you
want to
capture all the signal over here is
really tedious
so instead of doing that you can
actually
select multiple bands at a time by just
dragging
holding the shift down and dragging over
all those
bands and then copying them
and pasting and then you can now move
them to the new location as
you want or you can the other way to
select multiple bands is holding the
shift
and clicking on the bands one band at
the time
that works both ways similarly you can
resize the bands
you know either one band at a time by
using those handles
to resize right or move
all these functions can be performed on
one object at a time
or multiple objects i'm saying objects
because the same can be applied to the
lanes as well
if the lane if you need to skew a lane
go to skew lanes and then you can move
skill the lanes if the lane wasn't
identified correctly initially
and then once you're done with all your
adjustments
remember to apply because the data is
updated
only upon uh you know
committing your changes
so that is the basic lane and ban
adjustments that you can perform in
ibrite analysis software
and they're all located up front over
here now i'll just show you where our
analysis workflows workflows are located
so you can go to the analysis here and
click on that
and select the workflows from the drop
down menu
clicking on the markers will allow you
to perform molecular weight analysis
selecting quantitate will allow you to
perform relative or absolute
quantitation you can select one or the
other
or you can select normalize and then you
can perform either
normalization using a housekeeping
protein
or total in protein-based normalization
for today's seminar we are going to
concentrate on just the marker workflow
there will be other seminars going in
depth over each of these workflows at a
later time point
so once you select the markers you have
to go and select the lane which contains
your
marco standards however as i mentioned
right we are in the kemi channel
that was selected for editing so you do
not see the bands
selected uh from the membrane channel so
you you have to change the
channel for editing so that now you can
see
the uh the true signal coming from the
membrane channel
if you want to go ahead we did not spend
time
on getting rid of the non-specific bands
on the membrane channel
or making sure that all the bands were
identified actually if you see here
there will be
other very faint bands you know the high
molecular weight bands that did not get
transferred
so you can either go back to the frames
and
add the missing bands or there's another
way to handle it which i'm going to show
you
so come back to the markers right and
select the lane
in which you have the protein standards
and then choose a marker
by default we have around 10 molecular
weight markers standard
already pre-loaded in our analysis app
if these are not the standards that you
have used
you can go to add or edit custom markers
and create your own custom marker and
save it
and for today as i've said we are going
to be using one of
uh the preloaded markers okay i have to
select that
layer right and then go we have used the
eyebrite
molecular weight ladder so we know that
so we're going to select that
however since i said that this band was
not selected
i know that these do not align correctly
so
i have to drop the 250 molecular bit
marker because that band was not
identified
the way i would do that is by going to
the tool area
and you know deselecting it so i'm
telling the software
to ignore the 250 marker because that
doesn't exist
in our image similarly if you see
all these lower bands this is where the
sample buffer was running
and therefore any analysis in this area
will not be accurate
so i'm going to drop the the last band
as well
so now that you're satisfied with what
you see here over here
i think even that is so there you go
you can apply and say that okay now
perform my molecular weight analysis
using the standards that are shown you
can go to the graph
to look at your molecular with
regression analysis
so by default we show point-to-point
regression analysis however
you can change it to either linear or
linear semilog and most often linear
semilog works better
but i'm not going to change that for
today's demonstration
what i'm going to show you is how to
look at your data from the chemi
uh channel in this particular view right
so you can go up here and this is where
you can select the channel that you're
interested
in and go and select a lane and what
you'll see is
all the bands that are within that lane
are now represented in
on the standard curve so this is how you
can tell
the molecular weight of your bands
so if you're happy with your data you
can
say done and exit the workflow and go to
your main analysis tab
or you can go to the data table
so in this particular view you do see
the data table and
also the image on the side it makes it
easier for you to compare between the
image that you're seeing and the data
that is associated
with it in this you can
add more columns to the data table
by choosing this hamburger menu
if you had performed a particular
analysis
then the column is automatically added
for example if you had performed rolling
ball background correction
that would have already been added by
default we always perform the local
background correction so
that is already there we also by default
show you the density
if you do not want you can just toggle
those off
and remove it from the view it just
hides the columns the data is always
available and i want to look at the band
purity
right i mean you can always toggle that
on if you if you
want to look at that right
so this is where you know all the the
tools are located for
you know what you want to see in the
data table or what you want to hide
i'm going to close it and if i'm
wondering
if i'm interested in just seeing the
data for this band right so i can click
on that
what it does it is it highlights the
band in the viewport
as well as it brings the data associated
with that right to the top of the data
table
making it really easy to align the band
with the data the reverse can also be
done i can select a band
data in the data table and now the
band will be highlighted so now again
it's easy for me to associate and see
you know the band which this data
belongs
there's another option as well as you
can see there's so many bands over here
right and
when i'm exporting data or when i'm
creating a report i may not
want information for all these plans so
i can go and select this filter option
what it does is it creates an empty
table and lets you start adding the data
that you wish to see
so for example i'm only interested in
these bands
so i can just go and select those bands
right and then it'll just give me filter
the data for those
bands so that's another option that we
have in the
data table so once you
are happy you have looked at the data
you're satisfied you can exit the data
table
using the close you know just close it
and then you will land back
in the workflow that you start and then
you can exit and go to the main
um analyze data tab by clicking on the
frames
so that was the basic analysis that can
be performed in the hybrid analysis
software
i wanted to take a fluorescent image
because there are
few other options that are available for
fluorescent images
so here as you can see right i mean it's
a multi-channel image it's a four
channel
image three fluorescent channels and one
membrane
so this image looks pretty neat right i
mean there's hardly any background that
you can see
that is because of the option that we
call as auto
enhance what auto enhance does
is that it will remove the non-specific
background
from the image leading to a nice and
crisp
clean image in the image display
i do want to emphasize that none of this
image display
enhancements that are applied whether it
is auto contrast
or to enhance show saturation or false
color
none of this affect the raw data so your
analysis
is always performed on the raw data
so there is no data manipulation your
analysis is not hindered to by making
this
changes so if you wanted to see the true
background
of your image just click the author
enhancer off
and you can see how much background is
coming from the different channels
you can you your toggle off the auto
contrast as well
right
right to see your full stretch
and that depends upon you know which
channel you have you're looking at
but basically
that is how you can look at individual
channels the other thing that i forgot
to mention actually
is you when you're in uh performing
analysis
it is always better especially when
you're in the fluorescent channel
because it's really difficult to see
these very fine baths
it is easier to go to the grayscale
right
and here in your viewport you're only
shown a single channel
and you're shown as black on white so
it's much easier for you if you adjust
over here it's much easier to see the
signal
you know in those bands and if you had
applied these kind of
adjustments to the color mode right your
image
may not look good right so that is why
we don't actually
perform such drastic image adjustments
when you're in the color mode
so i'll go and now i'll just do auto
contrast
and then i'll apply auto enhance
so the image looks good and like i said
if you want to look at
the signals a little better go to the
grayscale and you can just keep moving
between the channels
you will be seeing one channel at a time
and since day is higher excuse me
this higher background in the
fluorescent channels another tool that
you can use to
make sure that you are getting good band
coverage is
view lane profile
so once you launch the lane profile
select a lane
and what it does is it will show you the
lane profile
on your right and it also shows you the
band location
right the peaks for each of those bands
and the band coverage
so once you select the band you can see
the red area that you can see over here
you can see that there
is some area that is not covered by
the band that is shown over here
to work easily you can just go zoom in
and you can adjust the band over here
right and you should update in real time
in your
graph and you can
this way make sure that you're capturing
all the signal that belongs to the bat
and here you can increase it a little
bit right
okay so now you can see that it is
pretty good coverage
and once you're done adjusting all the
bands that way
you can apply in this particular
mode right in within the lane profile
you cannot adjust
more than one band at a time you have to
work with a single band
and in this tool in this area if you
notice you do have other options
you know to perform rolling ball
background correction and those again
will be covered at a later date so for
today's presentation
um this is what we wanted to show
through the lane profile that you can
adjust band coverage very well if you
use
the link profile option
you can close the link profile over here
and then
move back to
the analysis the main analysis
okay so i think that
that is basically what uh we wanted to
show as a part of demonstration today
for the analysis so next step
i have analyzed my image right and uh
we have adjusted we are happy with the
adjustment so next step would be to
annotate the image
so again i'm going to select an image
that i've previously annotated because
there's a lot of annotations that can be
applied
and i'll just show you how to use the
tools in this
so again if if the image was analyzed
and you want to label the links or the
frame
or the channel name it is the it is
easiest to do that
using the data table so you can go
and click in the link that you want to
add the label
and then so for me the first lane would
be molecular weight marker
so i'll just add that and then
you can save it and once you add the
label over here it is now displayed in
the viewport
similarly i can add a label for the
frame
if this is a single frame so it doesn't
it may not matter that much but
as i mentioned that we do a lot of
multiframe analysis right so
it is always good to label frames as
well
so what i'm going to do is i'm just
going to label it with
uh with the cells that i used in that
experiment
when you have that you can see that the
frame labels
appear at the bottom of the frame
you can hide the labels using this
eyeball
the same same same feature
as show or hide the channel right
click on the eyeball hide it
the annotation goes away and click it
once again
and now you can see the annotation come
back on so you can individually control
what annotations you want to show in the
viewport right once you label it
you can label the channel name
channel as well as the bands individual
bands
right i mean i can expand this and label
the band as well however
those annotations do not appear in the
viewport
but they will be exported when you
export
uh the data as an excel it is more
important to have that for documentation
purposes
rather than you know overloading the uh
image in the viewport with a lot of
annotations
so we do allow you to uh annotate the
pans
as well as the channels
however they will be exported with the
data and not shown in the viewport
the other way to annotate the image if
you wanted to just
you know give a title to the image or
you know as i've shown over here
just add some text annotations um you
can go
click on the text and click in the
viewport where you want to add the text
and add the text over there
so in this case i will just say you know
this text
you can change so in this case ls
magenta right magenta color is
selected by default
whereas i can you can also select the
color that you want
so in this case i want to change it to
blue i can change it
right and then you can do the same with
the you know shape annotations i can add
a two
i can add an arrow i can draw a box
if i wanted to highlight this for
example right i can add a box around it
the thing to remember if you're going to
highlight is not to use a fill color
because then that is going to cover your
text right
otherwise if i wanted to create a white
box over here
then i can just draw a box and i'll
i can use the white color to fill it
right so that is how you can
use some of the shape and the text
annotations over here
so um another thing again to remember
over here
i think i did not mention i should have
mentioned it at the beginning of the
annotations
is to make sure that
you are adding annotations to the
correct channel
we are viewing the uh composite image
again
however the text annotations that i just
added
i added it to channel 800 because that
is what was selected for
editing however maybe that is not my
intention right because
akt is not in the 800 channel it is in
the super signal west jira right
so if i now go to that particular
channel
right say
i have the akt but i don't have the box
that i added around it
so it is very important for us to
remember
that when you are in the composite mode
the modifications that you are doing
right that apply to the individual
channels
will be added to the channel that is
selected for editing
so in this case what i would suggest is
if you want to
add annotations to a specific
channel go to the grayscale right go to
that particular channel
and add the annotations there the
annotations that are added
in this channel will appear in the
composite image automatically
it ensures that you are putting the
annotations at the correct place
and since the lane and the frame is
common to
all the channels you will see the lane
and the frame annotations coming through
all the channels so
this is safe to do in the composite
image
but when you're labeling the specific
signal
that belongs to only one channel go to
that particular channel and add the
annotations there
and then when you come back to the
composite image you will see all the
channels together
so that is what we have in a nutshell
for our annotations tab
so what we have demonstrated today is
how to take an image from the gallery
adjust the image perform some basic
analysis and annotate and one thing that
i forgot to mention when we were in the
gallery so when we go back to
let me go back to the gallery and let me
show you that
is when i mention the file management
you can delete the images right but to
delete the images
you have to select the images and add
them to the tray
and then go to actions menu and hit
delete
and when you hit delete it is going to
remove
all the images in the trace so please
make sure that you are
truly only having the images that you
are interning or deleting
okay and the other options
they're common features that are present
across all the workflows
and they will be analysis report
image and image export so for analysis
report right
you so analysis report is usually uh
will be created for the image that is
selected
so we want to create an analysis let me
go back to annotate since
you know that is where we were working
and yeah before i forget another thing
that i wanted to let you guys know
if the image was not annotated uh
was not analyzed when you came to the
analytic table
and then you feel that you it would have
been easier if you had performed
analysis
you will have an option here to auto
analyze it you won't have to go back to
the other tabs
to perform analysis you'll be able to
perform analysis and
annotate it from the same place okay
so now to show you how to generate an
analysis report
so under the actions menu click on
analysis report
and it will show you all the options
that are available
you can either generate uh the pdf so
the
analysis report is always exported as a
pdf
so the page orientation you can select
either portrait or landscape
if you select portrait and if you have
too many columns
data columns then it's going to wrap
around and you you're going to have a
bigger
report so based on the number of columns
that you have
select either portrait or landscape
whether you want to include the images
and do you want to include the layers on
the images do you want to show the
analysis objects or not you can show or
hide those
features over here you can include the
data table and
also the chart the chart here is you
know the chart that
i showed you when we were performing
molecular weight analysis
or if you had performed absolute
quantitation
there is a regression chart that goes
with absolute quantitation as well
so that is the chart that you can either
include or exclude
so in this particular case i can include
the chart as well
i'm selecting the portrait for my page
orientation i'm including everything
that i can get
and then hit preview
you can scroll down and see how your
report looks
obviously we did add a few annotations
that shouldn't have been there but
that's okay
right and if you're satisfied with what
you're looking at
oh that's the chart and these are the
tables right we didn't have that many
uh data columns so it's fitting really
well
uh in the report if you're happy with
what you see
you can you know select the download
icon and you can download and save the
file
i do want to open a few more columns
just so that i can tell you how
i can show you how it looks
okay if you haven't performed those
there it will not add that anyway so the
columns will be empty
let's see if we can see those
see now we can see many more columns in
the
repo and the same thing if you had um
generated the report as portrait
then you would have seen the columns
wrapping around
so that is a good feature to have is
based on the amount of data that you
have
select the page orientation
and now for image export so there are
two ways that you can
export image files one by right clicking
in your viewport
it allows you to just export one file at
a time
and in this this is the place where you
can
select whether you want to export it for
publication or for analysis analysis
always exports the raw data so none of
the modifications that you had done
image enhancements or you know previous
analysis
annotations none of those are retained
if you select analysis
in the publication you have option to
select between three file types
and you can also select uh the
resolution that you would want
to apply on your image to export
and you you can as well you can also
define the size of the image that you
would like to export it as
the aspect ratio for the image is always
fixed because we don't want the image to
be distorted
so your you can either input the height
or the width
and the second dimension is
automatically calculated
and as i mentioned it also you also have
the option
to include annotations or exclude
annotations so based on your selections
made over here
the image that is exported will either
contain the
uh lanes frames and bands or annotations
or not
the other feature that we have right
over here is file rename
so this is the place where you can
rename your file during export so for
example
if i wanted to export this file to share
with a colleague right so i can say
share
with or if i wanted to say this is a
image for a publication right so i can
put that
or right now i'll just say you know
complete
that's right and i can export
based on whatever file name that i want
one thing to remember is that if you
rename your file during export it is the
new file name is only applied to the
exported file
the image that is in the gallery will
not be renamed
so if you want to rename a file
and in your gallery you can do so i'll
show you how to do that as well
so basically rename here and if you were
doing batch export it will tell you the
total you know file size of your
exported file so you can understand
you know how much space it's going to be
occupying whether you can put it in a
thumb drive or not
for during your export you can browse
for the location where you want to
uh save the file and then you can once
you select
the location then your export will get
activated and you will be able to export
it
and for if you want to export it for
analysis
you have the option of exporting is the
either stiff
or g2i if you selective
all your if it's a multi-channel image
your channels will be exported
separately
each channel as a tiff file and you can
take those tiff files
and analyze them in a third party
software if you wish to do so
but if you want to share it with the
colleague to be reanalyzed or used in
the ibed analysis software
export it is a g2i because this is the
only file format
this and the vid file are the only two
file
file formats that are imported into
our hybrid also software none of the
other
file types are compatible with the
hybrid analysis software
okay so that's basically the options
that we have for image export
and let me just quickly go and show you
how to rename files
so to rename file uh files in the
gallery
you just click over there select that
and then you can put a new name give it
a new name and that name
will be saved so that is how you can
rename files in this
um hybrid analysis software
so i hope you learned something today um
and uh you you will be willing to give a
hybrid analysis software a try
so good luck with that thank you all for
listening
i'll turn it over to jennifer now
thank you dr narahari for your
informative presentation
before we start our q a session we
received a few notes in the chat
that the image report was not displaying
on the screen
as dr narahari presented we were
experiencing
some technical issues but can share an
example image report if needed after the
webinar to anyone that is interested
please follow up by email if you are
interested
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
let's get started our first question is
how many frames can i analyze with
multi-frame analysis
okay thank you for your question so um
what i uh understand the question is
about is
you know in an image how many
independent frames can be analyzed
so that as i've mentioned in my seminar
um
on the instrument you can image four
mini blocks or four gels and therefore
on the instrument
all the four can be now in independently
analyzed
when you come to the analysis software
though uh we remove the
restriction of only analyzing up to four
independent
blossom images here in the analysis
software
uh we have successfully uh analyzed up
to eight to twelve
independent frames so yeah you can
image up to four many blocks or many
gels and you can create additional
frames and you can analyze multiple
frames independently
independent of each other
thank you dr narahari our next question
can ibright analysis software be used to
support fda regulation 21
cfr part 11 compliance
yes uh our instrument i've written our
ibright imager
as well as analysis software do provide
21 cfr part 11 support
um on the instrument if you're already
uh
if you have already purchased an
instrument and the current user you can
purchase just the support uh part of the
21cfr part 11 licensing
support for the analysis software we do
have a specific installer a separate
installer for the analysis software that
can be downloaded
and once you have purchased the license
you can
go ahead and install the software and
use it for 21cf or part 11 support
but however i do want to make it clear
that just using our instrument
and the analysis software doesn't
provide you complete
compliance compliance to achieve total
compliance
you do have to follow your institute's
policies
uh procedural policies as well as the
technical support provided by our
instrument and diagnosis software
thank you again dr narahari and we have
another question
can western blots be used to quantitate
protein amounts
using eyebrite analysis software
yes so as i understand this question
the user would like to estimate
the amount of an unknown protein
it can be done through analysis software
the option is located under analysis and
we call it absolute quantitation
where the user can go and create a
standard graph
however the experiment needs to be set
up appropriately
for that function right i mean the user
should have a purified protein
uh diluted at different con you know
loaded at different concentrations so
that they can now have a good standard
curve
and there's some other additional um
experimental conditions that you should
keep in mind uh all the data should be
within the linear range and such
so if you're interested please reach out
to our technical support and they'll uh
put you in touch with us uh if you need
guidance on the experimental conditions
uh
you can reach out to the technical
service and we'll be more than happy to
support you on that
thank you dr narahari we have one final
question
i noticed i noticed during the analysis
portion of the presentation that the
eyebrite protein ladder selected in lane
1
for molecular weight analysis didn't
have the two distinct
hemi signal bands that i'm used to
seeing in addition to the pre-stained
marker bands
can you comment on that
sure just give me one second let me
check on what you're saying
maybe i selected the wrong lane uh to
designate as my protein standard
and yes thank you very much for your
question
i did select lane one which is actually
not the eyebright protein standard
i should have selected lane two that
contains the eyebright uh
protein ladder so uh thank you for
catching
that mistake and uh making us aware of
it
um so yes if you look at lane two you
will see the two kemi
uh bands the standard the control bands
that are there in the eyebread protein
ladder
so yes a good catch there thank you
thank you dr narahari do you have any
final comments for our audience
today thank you very much for your time
i really enjoyed giving this
presentation and i hope you uh
gained some knowledge uh on how to use
eyebrow analysis software
please don't hesitate to reach out to
our technical support in case you have
any further questions
thank you again dr narahari for your
time today
and for your important research we would
also like to thank
labruts and our sponsor thermo fisher
scientific for underwriting today's
educational webcast
stay tuned for our second webinar coming
on april 29th
which will cover more in-depth workflows
including quantitation and normalization
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye